[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm coming to you from the interval
where i will be joined by our speaker
tonight peter lydon
to watch the pre-recorded version of his
talk with you all and answer questions
live afterwards
peter has been a long time fellow
traveler with long now and has worked
with many futurists
authors and scientists over the past few
decades he periodically has assembled
that work
into his writings in places like wired
magazine to lay out some of those
predictions
tonight's talk is based on his latest
effort called the transformation
that puts forth some of the seismic
changes he sees defining the next three
decades and beyond
welcome peter lyden
thank you xander and it is a real honor
to be speaking here to the long now
community it's a community that i have
felt a part of for the last
25 years i'm particularly indebted to
several of your founders
kevin expanded my understanding of
technology peter about economics and
business
steward about civilization and long-term
thinking and
all three of them are fundamentally
optimists and i
share the basic worldview of all three
of them as well as their optimism
and optimism actually figures into this
project it started about two years ago
and we were just surrounded with a
despair
kind of a zeitgeist of despair in this
country and really around the world
it's despair about that we will never be
able to solve the challenges of climate
change and global warming
that we'll never be able to deal with
the gross inequalities in america and
other parts of the world
that we wouldn't be able to deal with
our political polarization happening in
america and also throughout the west
and then ultimately we would never get
beyond the racial inequities and the
racial tensions that are still coursing
through the country
and people just have a fear of the
future they're just bombarded with
dystopian ideas of what the future could
bring
they can't imagine a better future ahead
to me there are so many positive
developments been happening and are
still happening here there's it just
doesn't map onto the story i see
it seems to me that there's a new
narrative of the story of our times
a positive narrative of what's actually
happening
and what's truly possible it seems like
we really need to tell a story of a much
better future that lies ahead
now one way to do this is to do what we
did
back in the 90s was to create a positive
but plausible scenario of the future to
let people kind of
see what actually that world could be
that's what we did at wired and that's
what we did
using the techniques of global business
networks foresight techniques and
scenarios
now today this process might best be
called speculative journalism
speculative journalism is not science
fiction which is just purely imagining
another future
it's also not neutral scenario planning
looking in all directions equally
but essentially it's a rigorous
journalistic process of research and
reporting to kind of understand more
deeply what lies ahead
to me the way i think of it is you start
with a positive reframe
you start to think about what are the
underappreciated positive trends out
there
what are new technologies just beginning
to scale but still kind of under the
radar
you also need to do some deep reporting
with remarkable innovators who are
looking ahead and helping invent that
future
and so this project i really had deep
long interviews with 25 key ones
many are from the long now network many
of these folks as well as others outside
this
network help me actually understand what
lies ahead in the next 30 years
so in the end at the end of last year
2020 i published a series of stories in
medium called the transformation
it tells the largely positive story
of 2020 to 2050 from the perspective of
someone
in 2100 but it's more than a story
it's the best case of what i think is
largely happening and could possibly
happen in the next 30 years
i think we're on the verge of another
technology and economic boom that could
dwarf the one we just went through
through the last 30 years
it may be not just a long boom a second
long boom two
but a societal transformation and in
fact we could be making great progress
on all
four of the areas challenges that i
mentioned beginning including like
climate change by 2100 if we have
solved climate change and when i say
solved i mean mitigated the worst
excesses and
successfully adapted to kind of live in
a thriving way
if we get through that we actually will
probably have gone through something
that's closer to a civilizational change
the era from 1980 to
that period may be understood as
something comparable to the
enlightenment
and in many ways it might supersede it
in every way that's ultimately why i
call this
whole project the transformation to make
that direct parallel
so in this talk i'm going to make the
best case to convince you
that we're heading into a bigger long
boom than
the one we've even been through and that
we're in the early stages of
civilizational change
now to start i think we should go back
to the precursor
the cover story eduard the book that
ultimately went into other languages
the long boom and in fact it's that
piece and that book that really is a
precursor to the talk i'm actually going
to be giving
today now this was a creature that mid
mid-1990s this was done 25 years ago was
created
and reported and written in 1996 and
published in 1997.
this was the beginning of the digital
revolution and the fir what i would call
the first era of globalization these two
things were kind of
biting right in the mid 90s but not
fully understood
we forget that when you go back there
there was a very similar situation there
was a lot of gloom there was a lot of
fear of the future
people just could not imagine what was
lying ahead with these digital
technologies and what else so what we
had to think about back at wired there
was what's the big story we're actually
in how could it unfold in positive ways
in the coming decades
what would that world look like in
effect we had to breathe life into
the digital global economy to be clear
it was a positive scenario one that just
focuses
mostly on the positive developments that
could happen it's not a prediction
still it's worth thinking about how did
we do and i'd argue that we were pretty
prescient
we got many of the major through lines
largely right
for example i think we pretty much
nailed the fundamental digital
technology developments at the
foundation moore's law
kept doubling remarkably steady this
wasn't necessarily going to be the case
for the mid 90s
the power of computers get getting
better and better
that actually played out the flip side
is the connections between those
computers played out perfectly too this
was not again inevitable but it was
inexorable
in fact in 1997 there was about 50
million people
on the internet basically one percent of
the global population today
close to 60 percent more than half the
world
if you look at us gdp from 1980 to 2020
it's just a steady upward climb
and particularly in the 90s it actually
just charted out
but again we weren't just talking about
america we were looking at the entire
global economy and in fact
the twin engine of this era was
globalization that integrated all these
economies and kept driving growth
in 1995 china's gdp was a mere
trillion dollars or so it ended in 2020
more than 16 trillion in the process
they pulled 800 million peasants out of
poverty
and became a superpower all projected in
our story
now for sure we got a lot wrong uh and
you know what do you expect telling a
story of the world for the next 25 years
but i'd like to focus on just a few that
are relevant to this talk
these were ones that i could learn from
going forward and try to correct for in
this new project
now storytelling trap is one i think
about it's
a story of the future is still a story
it's hard to tell a story without
details but given details about the
future
lays a minefield for the future when you
come
up to those dates we had some good
projections like when a microprocessor
hit
10 billion calculations 2010 but we
failed at how long it would take to get
to dealing with genetic diseases we
thought 2015.
and we ended our story with you know
humans making it to mars but of course
that was way off so it's hard to avoid
this storytelling trap
the other one's a little more
fundamental innovation by definition
can't really be predicted
it starts with an act of creativity out
of someone's head
and so much of the digital global
economy was driven by innovation you
know how do you breathe life into that
a striking example of this is laid out
in brian eno's 25th anniversary edition
of his diaries from 1995
a year with swollen appendages he talked
about all the words that did not exist
25 years ago
if you scan through that list it's just
remarkable when you see
how many things just happened how many
names
just appeared in the course of 25 years
now how could a speculative journalist
come up with even a fraction of these
another one
has to do with issues that are rooted in
politics
there were many times when politics just
screwed up basically screwing up the
scenario screwed up what could flow out
there were things that we did not think
about but kind of diverted huge
attention and resources like when the
terrorists hit the world trade center
and we went off to start
not one war but two or there's things
that
could have happened but politics kind of
got in the way
for example george bush defeating al
gore by a few disputed votes
in 2000 now we talked a lot about how
climate change would get addressed more
aggressively in our scenario
would president gore have done that
presumably probably
more than the oral men george bush the
lesson from all this is politics
matter which we'll get to in a minute
here later the final one
i want to mention is amara's law
attributed to stanford professor roy
amara his quote is we overestimate the
impact of technology in the short term
and underestimate the effect in the long
run
this plays out in scenarios we need to
breathe deeply and slow down
everything takes longer than you think
so we thought the development of biotech
would
go much faster than in fact it did
and this makes sense when you think
about how government regulation might
slow that down we had all kinds of
things happening in that space
the same thing with climate change we
had alternative energy rolling out much
faster than in fact it happened and for
that matter we were much more bullish on
hydrogen fuel cells we clearly were
trapped in time
so that's the past but what about the
future what about the next year what
about this era from 2020 to 2050
the primary way to start thinking about
that next period is to understand the
underlying tools and technology really
for any era they define what's possible
and they constrain what's
not possible so if you start out looking
forward on in technology
you realize that we might be heading
into three world historical tech booms
there's one in information technology
there's one in biotechnology and there's
one in energy technology
now one of the things we learned in that
last version of the long boom is that
you can get pretty
reliably close to the general
tech and economic through lines now i
had some help from kevin kelly who wrote
a book called the inevitable
about how certain technologies are
inevitably going to happen
and kevin's a little more clear on
exactly what you think is going to
happen
in my case i think what i'm going to
talk about these
inexorables are not fully inevitable but
rather
inaccurately moving ahead they're going
to be hard to stop we could maybe
channel them or thwart them or slow them
down a little bit
but in general they're going to play out
over the next
10 to 30 years now arguably
all of these things i'm talking about
could be positive developments
there are some dangers as well but
generally positive ones from my point of
view
the first category is let's look at
information technologies
now as big a deal as the last 30 years
were
we got another 30 years to go i think of
it as infotech stage 2
and the first big thing to focus on is
universal connectivity the next 10 years
we're basically going to get the second
half of the planet online
we've got all kinds of operational
projects trying to do this
low orbit satellites like starlink from
elon musk
and we've got all kinds of things trying
to also boost up the bandwidth to get to
5g
so let's think that one through if you
really think about it
looking ahead asia still has about half
its people
are not online africa in the middle east
has about two-thirds still not online
latin america about 40 percent to go so
a continued driver of a technology
expansion and off that an economic boom
is just on the same mechanism that we
saw play out
in the last 30 years now think about
that for a moment
in 2000 you really only had a handful of
americans online
by 2030 you're gonna have everyone on
the planet
online now on the backs
of all those global connections is going
to come ai and so we're starting to see
now how
ai can be used it's an incredible
extension of human capabilities
but we're eventually going to get to
ubiquitous ai
we're going to have all digital data
it's going to be captured in the cloud
it's going to be accessible to everyone
at all times
and ai's going to plumb that in myriad
ways
one of the ways it's going to actually
do it is
getting to natural language translation
by ai particularly this is going to be
useful with the second half of the world
coming online who are not
educated elites not able to speak a
second language
the business language of english so what
i think we're also going to see here is
a secondary effect of this connections
of what i would call
accelerated innovation innovation is
that making cross-connections between
people from different perspectives
different fields different expertises
and if you start to think through the
impact of that kind of
cross-fertilization not just
across ideas but across cultures across
classes
all this mosh pit of cross connection is
going to happen in the next 10 years
now the flip side of this is kind of
related to a forward projection of
amera's law
it's hard to predict how humans are
going to leverage a powerful new tool
like
a.i too many people are focused on the
negative possibilities
how many are factoring it into our
abilities to solve our biggest
challenges
we will need ai and i think we will
fully use ai
over the next 30 years to solve these
biggest challenges i think it's going to
end up
a net positive and to our benefit for
sure
so that's infotech then there's this
whole world
of biotechnology our genetic
understanding is already leading to big
strides in human health
the mrna breakthrough that just came
through in the pandemic is just a taste
of things to come
i think we're finally ready to see
biotechnology's full
impact arguably biotech is where
infotech was in the 1990s now the
fundamental drivers of information
technologies
that drove the lost long boom have to do
with exponential drops in
costs allowing exponential rise in scale
it turns out that the cost curve in
genome sequencing
is beating moore's law at this point in
2000
it cost two billion dollars to
crack one human genome by 2010
that cost had dropped to two million per
one human
genome today it's less than a thousand
bucks there's some limit but
ultimately you can imagine over the
course of the next decade it's going to
be super cheap if not
close to free so i think we're
underestimating how we could reinvent
healthcare
now we're still in the very early days
of crispr techniques but we're on the
road
to widespread genetic engineering and we
are
already moving beyond human health
problems into synthetic biology now this
is not just
genetic engineering but wider biological
engineering
we now are understanding how cells work
as well
as how the genome works and we're able
to apply that now not
basically to all living things so for
example we're already seeing how it's
impacting
food and ultimately starting to grip
into cell-based meat
we could be seeing close to 40 to 50
percent
of the meat we eat could actually be
cell-based meat over the course of this
period we're talking about here
and we could see truly sustainable
materials to replace let's say
the scourge of plastics that's mounting
all over
all these things in the biotech field
could help our ongoing challenge of
dealing with climate change i think we
could see a complete inversion of how we
produce
things a fundamental shift to actually
grow things
with very little waste from the bottom
up
then there's the whole world of clean
energy technologies
the third world of technologies to talk
about now they
are following the classic tech cost
curve down
and they're also hitting the inflection
point of scaling up
let's take solar which is the most
dramatic and it's kind of the classic
example
we needed that last era the long boom
era to drive the cost down to compete
and undermine carbon energy it took 40
years but we're now there
when we began the last era around 1980
it was like 76
bucks a watt for solar power last year
was down to 22 cents that's a 350 time
price decrease and what do you know
we're watching the ramp up going on the
other side as those costs came down the
scaling went up in exponential fashion
in the last decade
we're now at about 700 gigawatts
globally still a long way to go to
displaced carbon
again but remember what the scaling of
digital technology was
in the 1990s in fact if you pull back
and look back in the last 20 years you
can actually see how the installed
solar globally has risen in logarithmic
scale
granted from a very low installed base
but now the scaling itself
is driving the cost down every doubling
of the industry installed base
drives the cost down 30 to 40 percent
which keeps up the virtuous circle of
growth
the same dynamic is happening in
electric vehicles in just the last
decade the cost of battery packs for
electric cars have been driven down
to be almost fully competitive with
internal combustion
engines but if you look out for the next
decade
they're expected to drop another three
to five times
and in the next few years or so they're
expected to be cheaper than internal
combustion engines and so across the
board better
easier to maintain safer and cheaper
fuel
and so what do you know you're watching
the ramping up just
starting we're still again just in the
last decade we're starting to ramp to
about seven million electric cars
were sold globally last year again still
a long way to go
but remember the 90s and the tech ramp
up
so to sum up you have three world
historical tech booms
all three are geared to full global
markets but to really solve these big
challenges we're going to need
politics politics can and does screw
things up as we mentioned
but the flip side is that politics
matters good politics can
solve problems that's not to say that
politics is
random the basic pendulum swing between
progressive and conservative errors this
back and forth that's played out over
american history
but we watch how power shifts to more
people-based power and progressive eras
and then back to more business power
in conservative areas how the core
values move from a more collective sense
in progressive areas to a more
individualistic sense in
conservative era we've watched this
pendulum swing over time
back and forth in fact if you go back 80
years
very similar situation to today the
1930s we had extreme political
polarization and paralysis we had
mounting authoritarian nationalism
but that opened up a long run of a
progressive era really a 40-year
boom this was the textbook case strong
government build infrastructure spread
wealth the democrats
dominated that era but both parties work
within the context for example nixon
extended the great society
as a republican but the end of that run
in the late 70s it was
becoming outdated out of ideas out of
energy
and so the handle swung again and so
then you watched essentially
a conservative era open up 1980 brought
ronald reagan to the presidency in about
a 40-year run
of the conservative dominated time the
boomers dominated the politics they're
much more individualistic and
turned out to be conservative the
republicans dominated but both parties
worked within bill clinton reformed
welfare for example
but again by the end of this period the
last decade it ended up outdated out of
ideas
and pretty much corrupt so i would argue
a strong case we're entering another
progressive era
this is not wishful thinking but it's
built on the inexorables
this time demographic ones these cycles
are driven by
deep demographic forces that build
ascendant coalitions
the first is a generational shift
the dominant generations of an era
largely drive the politics
generations have personalities and value
sets
that pretty much hold through life the
gi generation coming off of fdr
drove the last progressive era the
boomers coming off
when reagan ascended kind of drove the
last 40 years
so what about this one that's opening up
it's going to be driven by millennials
now these millennials have much less
stake in the current society they
amassed
very little wealth in the last run and
they are much more transformative in
their thinking
think bernie sanders that's who is
behind him
but if you then add the generation z
that's those people born from 1997 to
2012.
this generation of generation z is very
very similar to the value
set of the millennial generation they
seem to align very clearly in all the
polling up to now and it looks like a
very little distinguishes between the
two of them
we're going to see with those two
generations a double-barreled
power that's going to push for more
transformative change at the same time
if you look how it plays out the boomers
are literally retiring in mass and dying
off
by 2040 the youngest boomers not oldest
are now age 75 and the oldest
they really are passed away by 2040 the
oldest millennials are just
hitting their 50s and they're pretty
much running everything the generation
behind gen z
who knows might be budding conservatives
it's not just generations there's other
inexorables too growing numbers of
people of color
immigrants tend to have higher birth
rates so in fact
america is clearly on track to be a
majority minority
population by the early 2040s this is
inexorable it's happening
then there's also the relentless
migration to cities
the superstar cities on the coast have
been the early ones to benefit from this
but all cities even
in the heartland people are going to the
cities today only
20 percent of america is in rural areas
by 2030 it's projected to be only 10
people in cities correlate to being more
cosmopolitan
and more progressive think about the
politics final thing to mention is
education
college grads now are more than a third
of all americans
younger generations are more than 60
percent are in college
or have been into college education
strongly correlates to belief in science
facts climate change now how does this
play out in politics all these
demographic inexorables hit california
first
remember california was a red state it
invented modern conservatism it was the
home of ronald reagan and the tax report
but also california was the first to let
go of that conservatism
today all statewide offices are run by
democrats
this is going to play out over america
and it's already happening
particularly in states most like
california
like the southwestern united states if
you look at this 2004 map
of president bush you could see that
essentially
a lot of red states this was the high
water mark for republicans since ronald
reagan
all those southwestern states are red
if you look at the last election it just
happened with joe biden and kamala
harris the southwestern states are all
four of them are blue
just in those 16 years we went from zero
electoral votes
blue in 2004 in the southwest to all 31
blue in 2020.
we also went from only two democratic
senators
in 2004 out of that region to all eight
in 2020 and then if you look at that map
you see the state of georgia the heart
of the door old south went blue
why the same in extra bulls young people
immigrants people of color the urban
area of expanding
atlanta and the educated people in the
suburbs this
is the blue america thing going to the
heart of
red america 2. so if you think through
the politics of the 2020s it's
pretty much going to be a blue lock on
the presidency
and an increasing balance in the senate
this is again
counter to the way people think about
this now but it's i think inexorable
remember in this election texas was in
play
it's probably gonna flip blue in 2024
it has the same dynamic as all those
southwestern states
including high rates of people of color
and immigrants north carolina was in
play even south carolina was
talked about in play this time this is a
pendulum swing and it is only swinging
one way we are entering a new political
era
one inexorable is going to be
reinvigorated government
we're going to go for the general strong
government tenancy that's going to
invest in infrastructure and alike
i think we're going to see a rebalanced
economy to take on
mounting inequality young people people
of color
much of the coalition of that blue
america has been cut out of the wealth
that was engorged in the last era
and they're very attracted to
transformative policies like
bernie sanders and even beyond watch for
the traditional counterbalance to
corporations
after kind of having a free reign with
conservatives you're going to watch a
lot more kind of
regulation including in tech and i think
we're going to actually see
that wealth inequality being pushed back
in the realm of taxation too
the levels of inequality are now back to
where they were last seen in the
beginning of the great depression
where the top 1 own in assets as much as
the bottom 90.
this was the same phenom that helped
start the last progressive era with fdr
and that kind of rolled for about 40
years and it kind of rectified things
that was reversed again in the 80s with
the conservative era and now we're back
to where we started
expect taxes to go back to historical
norms and more
who was in the streets this summer
people of color and the two younger
generations
those two generations both are about
roughly
50 50 whites and people of color
they want no part of white supremacy
they embrace diversity there's no debate
in that
so i think we're going to see in a third
shot at rectifying
racial inequities in this country truly
i think it's going to be more like the
third reconstruction
the original one coming off the civil
war the second one
in the civil rights area of the 60s i
think we're going to see a third one
the final thing has to do with climate
change
there's almost zero climate denial on
those generations or in the coalition as
a whole so we're going to see government
gear up and set
high strategy goals and standards we're
also going to see business align with
this
given their workers and customers of
these generations finally we're going to
see climate cooperation
it's going to really make a difference
now if you're really trying to talk
about solving climate change then you
got to think globally
we've been mostly talking about america
the liberal democracy is the west
we have to adjust the lens to the big
picture global view as well
now we have a lot of these technologies
are inexorable and that they could scale
globally
it turns out there's other inexorables
at the global level too there's mega
trends that are
beyond tech that are quite fortuitous
they're largely positive developments
that could help us solve a lot of these
challenges too particularly climate
change
one of them is burgeoning capital we
have the technologies but do we have the
capital to transition
our entire energy system to transition
the economy to sustainable everything
well there's about a hundred trillion
dollars in capital markets sloshing
around right now it's all looking for
productive investments
and it's actually not getting the kind
of returns it wants i think the super
tanker of global finance is going to
move this decade and there's signs that
it's happening
much faster than people think another
inexorable
is chinese superpowers china has now at
the end
of their 30-year run become truly a
global super
power and we need them china
can actually move and act in ways that
the liberal democracies as of now
can't we're still debating in america
whether climate change is real
and china is just moving huge amounts of
assets
also the chinese model is much more
relevant to the developing world
they pulled 800 million peasants out of
the poverty into cities in the last 30
years
and that's something that has to happen
around the world which brings up total
urbanization
another inexorable in this last decade
the world tipped past 50 percent of the
world now in cities
it's about 55 now but it's heading to 80
percent by 2050.
this is essentially a good tendency for
the planet it lowers the human footprint
and brings many other positive
developments like empowering women
which lowers the number of children and
which essentially reduces population
pressures another global inexorable is
middle-class majorities just in the last
few years
the world crossed another milestone in
which we have now
50 of the people on the planet are
middle class
3.6 billion people now this is
considered middle class in a global
context these are people who can afford
maybe something like a refrigerator or a
motorbike or have some mild security
unlike people who are really destitute
or poor
now this is not what we think of in the
west
as the middle class those would be
considered more almost rich people
in a global context now middle class
majorities in a global context
is a good thing middle-class people
spend almost everything they make back
into the economy
driving economic growth middle-class
people tend to be a huge stabilizing
force in society
they demand good government they're
trying to get good learning and
education things that are good for
everybody in the long haul
by 2030 it's estimated that the world
will add another 1.7
billion middle-class people to their
ranks this again is global middle-class
people to their ranks
we're gonna have well over five billion
people
who are considered in the global middle
class
going forward beyond that point so in
summary i think we
can actually solve climate change it's
totally possible
it's plausible it's even probable i
would argue we can
when i say solve it we can mitigate the
worst that people are fearing
we can adapt to what's already in motion
already baked in and we can
create a life which many many people the
world can really thrive
a final point is that this is not just a
story
not just some imaginative sci-fi this is
a work of speculative journalism
reported
and researched it's a positive reframe
of the
actual story of our times it's a new
narrative of what's really going on
and what could well happen i think
we're beginning another set of
technology and economic long booms
i think this is going to give us the
tools and the resources to help solve
our biggest challenges
i think this may well lead to a social
transformation
and will be seen as the early stages of
civilizational change
now the long now is one of the few
places that can hear what i'm saying
and totally drag it there's few places
few communities out there that think out
30 to 80 years very few talk about
civilization
i think of the long now as a 21st
century royal society
it's driving a global conversation that
people need to hear
and it's a group that's maintaining
optimism
for the log hall i've been happy to be a
part of the long now for the last 25
years
and i'm eager to be part of it for the
next 25 years
the next generation i think the next 25
to 30 years are going to be an
extraordinary time
i think people in 300 years 500 years
a thousand years let's just say it 10
000 years
they're gonna look back on our era from
1980 to 2100.
i believe america is in one of the
biggest junctures in its history
i think the entire planet is in a world
historic
moment i think we're going to figure out
a 21st century system that works for as
many
people as possible for the long haul i
believe
we're in the transformation thank you